you
Oh
good Lola and welcome to the Friday
review of games hey right so how's the
sound doing we're not muted awesome
excellent my name is Ian knee Lewis with
me as always as Anne of Green Gables Dan
Galpin hey today we are drinking
actually today we're drinking different
stuff yeah dan is drinking a Drake's
dry-hopped pale ale and I'm drinking a
dogfish head chicory stout but only
because I'm ill mmm good point yeah yeah
so I guess it is the cure for illness
it's in general drinking a good chicory
stout or is that is that it no no I just
I just felt that the hops would irritate
my throat and sets that's very
interesting possibility i'll say you
know via hops in this drake's brewing
company dry hot pale ale are lovely they
have kind of apricot flavors to them
very very nice but this friday afternoon
so so walking we've got a great
collection of games you guys have always
have been busy nominating and really
that's got some fun stuff this week and
tomato we do enough so i don't how we
want to begin well i think i think it's
uh yo you might as well begin with
Ferdie burb because that that game is
just bizarre uh yeah I you know I it is
sort of the this combination of a
tamagotchi game Tamagotchi game and an
adventure game and
and it's kind of fun actually you know
it has a lot of different ways people
can explore it's definitely an android
game but we're playing this guy who is
very sad right now I don't even look at
the screen hopefully it's coming out
it's not coming out okay i see i see the
bad aspects all right there we are we
forgot that rato Meyer is the man he
literally has a kill switch to kill any
possibility of sound coming off this
tablet so just that sound it's fun
that's all yeah that's true that's true
so uh so the game actually is played you
know like many of these games where you
can get to manipulate the environment so
I can drag to say I want to you know
rain on these little crops here he's
looking really sad right now I suspect I
might need to feed him or something i
can do that i've got all sorts of items
here i can drag and drop and wait oh
there I had to drag the cherries wait
did you just grow beaver plants I grew
beaver plants I swear that this this
this game has no limit to its creativity
I also you also can grow cheese that was
one of the things that I that I grew
earlier and now my little guy is eating
the cheese and I have no idea whether
that's going to know he doesn't look
like it's making no he did not yeah he
didn't like that a lot of you cherries
what do you think cherries he's more of
a fan of cherries maybe maybe he needs
sleep let's put him in this put him in
the house a case it's kind of one
unhappy little fur neighbor it really is
and we can we can follow him into the
house and there's just there's a lot to
do in this game that does not seem to
have made him happy all you can actually
go and redecorate the house as well if I
want I can get rid of this picture and i
can replace it with another one of my
choosing and yeah i just don't know why
he's unhappy yes it's really sad maybe
he just needs to be didn't want that
maybe he really needs you to buy barrick
who did twenty five dollars a month it's
very possible
you know that's that's that's you know
because because that that was highly
relevant to what I'm doing here and then
I can also make him leave I think it's a
way to make him leave the house and I'm
not sure how I think if you just go
somewhere else he's gonna be there right
it should be what happens I thought
there was a way to actually make him run
out and again you can interact with all
sorts of things in the game you would
you get these beautiful dialogues from
Android but yeah it works kind of kind
of the the bit and this is actually one
of those rare games because it's really
it's really just an interactive
experience where pricing the back he
does exactly what we would expect it
just takes us right out and that's fine
that's that's for this style of game
that makes that's actually ideal
experience we kick back and we go
straight back into the game right but
let's be clear the reason that's an
ideal experience is because you can go
in and out of this game immediately
right there's no long loading process
you don't lose any progress you go back
you go back in and its immediate and you
haven't lost anything you're right back
where you were yeah and that's good
that's the way we expect the experience
to be you know it's kind of this sort of
a magical experience kind of like the
game itself which is kind of magical I
wish it were a little higher res that
being said it make it a little bit more
magical but you know the artwork is fun
it's all in kind of illustrator you know
kind of style and the the game is cute
and certainly wildly inventive and and I
think it's why I think it's fun i think
i think it's adorable little came as i
said for a new offer on a tablet it
plays really really well other than the
fact that to really really low res and
I'd love to see given that this artwork
looks all like vector art to me it would
be great to see an upgraded version of
the game it probably would compress
really well to even you know that this
kind of artwork tends to be you know
with just simple simple kinds of
compression you can you can usually
scale it up pretty well so I'd like I
would love to see that in the game but I
don't know what else what is what else
is there to say it it from from a UI
first active perspective it's doing most
of things right you know again it has it
as proper navigation handling it has
proper handling of music on the lock
screen although it's hard
that in this particular instance and it
it actually and it actually doesn't have
the buttons of shame on it so yeah you
guys did that riot I think honestly the
one thing that I would love to see that
I think would make it a little
accessible is a hint mode uh yeah yeah
it does kind of walk you through kind of
initial stuff but i but but you know
those are definitely a little more try
to figure out what's going on the other
thing that we it would comment noise
what's the game that we looked at last
we it wasn't on here i think booze and
one of our other meetings we looked at
an adventure game mm-hmm that felt a lot
like this yeah yeah which I was the one
come when I was gonna make was actually
about the market listing page of Ischia
that well let me let me just finish the
that the point was that this other game
which was very very similar in a lot of
ways you know drag stuff around make
plants grow yeah interact with the
environment so they had an interesting
thing that I hadn't seen before but kind
of took me back to the old days of bodom
and and the what was that thing you know
the magic pencil thing oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah you know with your magic marker
it is this this thing over the invisibly
what bad is a clue right right so anyway
they monetize on hints so you can
actually do they did an in-app billing
solution for hints and i think i would
use that of course i think that you will
be like that sentence on the internet
but well that's it's kind of funny
because of the the joke was that the
guys who made you know one of the
original sierra games realized that
their game was actually being pirated
more than it was being purchased because
they sold more hint books and they sold
copies oh i just bought two or three you
know what study around mahalo exact i
give them my friends right right so i
think it is an interesting idea and you
know it sort of sort of and it said the
joke was that I just should have given
the game away for free insult in books
and obviously that's sort of a sort of
happening now with some of the modern
monetization and then so we have really
video artifacts is really jerky and you
probably see how to display that you're
a little bit delight yeah try and
restart just the Maya consciousness all
right we'll be off the air for about
five or ten seconds cln all right so all
right great toe is just informed us that
we will be off the air for five or ten
seconds because we become too edgy edgy
and agony oh damn damn that's the way
our show rolls we'll see you in just a
minute okay we have our winner when we
ever monitor back eat our food oh you
cannot have it back right ariel are
welcome back to the Friday games review
I'm Ian knee Lewis and dad's Alvin hey I
can say my own name do I friends the
chick from The Secret Garden about with
lots of things about this hat I I'm
pretty sure the Hat was actually causing
the artifacting that we saw before now
that was caused me or that is just
wedding as well you know we interrupting
I hardly get rid of the Hat I know that
Matt is a critical yeah absolutely yeah
exactly that's right Matt yeah 20
minutes into the future that's right
okay and with that said let's go to our
futuristic game DeLorean that's right so
now we were actually asked to review the
lite version of the lorien but i'm going
to review the full version of how do we
always review the full version yeah you
know why because we have an expense
account if they're even why that is the
reason why okay though I thought I
thought it was I thought it was said
that the developer would sell one copy
at least I'm so mean for submitting to
our show I thought that was actually it
was it was our it was a curse art was
our friendly gesture goodwill but ok ok
doc you put his time machine inside of
his ilorin ya say that at least once I
it I didn't think it would come up in
the
course of conversation though so I just
you know put it out there so DeLorean is
actual is really is a shooter game it's
a it's a massive multible it shooter and
we're really excited because this is the
first time we've been able to show
something working really really well in
portrait mode in a long time on our show
with our grant with our brand new video
set up so well apparently if our encoder
is screwing up maybe it's not worth
that's true actually it may be so one
thing about the game is it actually it's
a pointer controlled game in fact you
can actually turn off the ship because
it's really not very important it does
track wherever you are it's written
using and engine I think this is a
really great game to show off all that
you can do with an antigen title we're
seeing all sorts of translation and
rotation you know you know zoom on all
these different sprite objects and you
can see it's really keeping up
wonderfully well and an engine is uh is
written against dalvik so this is not a
native application and but this is using
GL right so you affect that any affine
transformation on the sprites isn't
going to be a problem absolutely
question is how many objects can get on
the screen and it's actually quite a few
yeah I mean there's there's no problem
on a device like the transformer prime
so you know it does a lot of people say
hey do I have to write my game you know
using you know the native stuff and the
answer is really know for a lot of
things you know the main reason why
people do it is honestly for
compatibility so that so they can poured
it over to platforms that don't have our
cool support for tools but on you know
if you're if you're not you know
concerned about that there are some
really great solutions out there and an
engine is just getting been getting more
rich and robust as a time is gone time
has gone by so it's cool to see this and
that's slowed down by the way is
actually because I picked up a powerup
that's not actually that's not actually
slowed down because of the game so you
can see it's worked it's a really fun I
mean they've done they've done a really
really good job I'll show you one thing
however that that they should have
changed and that is with handling of the
back key first of all the game pauses
whenever you whenever you Reese whenever
you lift up your finger which is which
is interesting and then I can't help but
notice but it has a sideways restart
button is that
intended yeah artifact the hdmi god no
it's not it's kind of a weird artifact
the game I don't know why they do that I
because the game is being rendered in in
portrait mode you can see the buttons
are at the bottom so it's kind of odd to
have that there was forced into portrait
mode yeah actually that's what I mean
it's being forced into ports but I mean
it's not like the game is rendering in
landscape it against a portrait screen
this is really a true portrait game so
it was a little surprising to see that
I'll say the other thing that they do is
that you actually the back button quit
progress will be lost first of all why
are you losing progress want to hit the
back key you know is it really really
necessary can't we just like restart off
in the middle and the fact is these
levels are freaking long you know it
takes it takes minutes and minutes to
play through a level in mobile gamers
you know they want to play for five
minutes and then they want to go off and
do whatever they're doing it's very
difficult in this game so if I had
anything in a comment that i would say
please allow someone to really give them
the appeal feeling that they can leave
the game in the middle a level and come
back and if you do go to the home screen
that does happen but there's no reason
the same thing wouldn't happen on a back
transition the second thing is now that
we're here at this yes and no prompt you
can't actually at the back you get rid
of it you know we are now absolutely
stuck in the we're not actually handling
the back key in this incident back so
you should always dismiss the dialog
yeah it should always it should always
do something you know something it
actually changes the stage of things
like there are there are developers you
think well I'll just put up a toast it
says you can't use the back key here not
a good play not press this book yeah
exactly this button does not work I love
that yeah that doesn't count doesn't
count of water with your in the middle
of a tutorial and you never thought that
you would let the user exit there that's
not the way Android works Andrew it
allows a user to exit whenever it's
possible you know they're there are a
few times like during loading where it
can be really challenging still allow
the user to exit you know I mean it's
just you have to architect it and design
it into the game as much as possible so
yeah because otherwise you know you're
really just designing your game for the
13 year old after school demographic and
real people real gamers they can pay you
real money generally have lives and have
interruptions especially on a mobile
platform yeah it's very unlikely that
somebody's you know coming home
observing two hours after work to just
sit there and play mobile games well not
everybody's Dan Calvin absolutely you
know and so you know if you look at the
actual game itself if I go back and
click on the game and go back into it
after it does actually resume the game
where I left off so I just you know I
just need making sure that that the fact
that it can do that is bubbled up to the
user in as many ways as possible just
make sense you know that being said you
know this is kind of a minimum
acceptable thing to pop up something and
let the user know that progress will be
lost you know that's you know this this
this would not stop it from being
featured we'd probably be like why yeah
you can sure you can do a lot of you
know that's that's you know that would
be the the general the general consensus
I think coming from our QA staff but
I'll but he doesn't have the buttons
it's a shame it navigates reasonably
well through all the dialogues it plays
really well it's beautiful it looks
beautiful like a lot a lot of fun
power-ups the game design is good yeah
it's actually fun to play there's some
very very cool concepts in the game you
know there's a there's all sorts of
stuff you can pick up and wipe the
screen there's there's all there's a
there's additional bonuses give it if
we're shooting down you know numbers of
things in a row it's it's just cool i I
congratulations all right and let's go
on to the Nets move on but before we do
I just want to respond to some of our
YouTube condon enters and mention that
when we do this show I am not actually
hi I know looks at me not hi no I'm
actually just a little drunk not oh and
I have naturally dilated peoples yeah
that that's that I is true so let's move
on I with that in mind I think I just
thought you always went to the
optometrist before coming here that was
actually that's the red eyes all that
yeah so hot donut hot donut no I was
offering you a pastry oh yes so in our
next honest exciting game is hot donut
by game dogging but again again as you
can see we do see a game that is
letterboxd on the title screen which is
kind of sad it's also really low res
which is kind of sad there's a lot of
links to websites like the Facebook and
the Twitter link just go out to website
which is also kind of sad
but the game is actually really cool and
so I would love to see this the small
amount of letterboxing that's here go
away it's it's it would be nicer now I
believe if we actually are not an HDMI
mode there's less letterboxing really
yeah okay we're ranked oh we're gonna
pull the plug on hdmi all right just a
second here just so you know okay and
yeah let's let's look at it I guess not
know then it's just even on a topic yeah
same so so I'm letterbox I'm
letterboxing kind of set so let's go
back to the game alright hopefully so we
have game yes we've got game alright so
we're on alright so we gotta show me the
hot donut all rights a weird book yeah
so we're playing a hot donut and
basically the way it works is when
you're rolling down hills you want to
touch you want to release when you're
not you can dash in the air by pressing
with both thumbs as you see it's telling
you and if you actually start rolling
backwards it will kick you forward which
is very nice because it's often
otherwise you would often get stuck oh
this is going to be bad here yeah you're
actually often times you can get away
with not with not pressing it in these
early levels which is nice but the goal
is obviously to keep this sent this
feeling of momentum and I can't go back
and grab the Firefly so I'm going to
totally who almost died there I'm gonna
totally lose out on this level so
whether you're pressing the the you're
pressing it to become the donut I'm
pressing aid exactly so it to start
rolling I see so that's the key thing
who almost didn't make that one to know
all i can think of our old kurt vonnegut
quotes at this point exactly so uh so
yeah saw is what is it about your
rolling doughnut it rolls faster than
when you've got the cape yeah exactly i
wrap my eye that the character wraps up
inside you can also buy important stuff
in in the game you have to buy you can
buy more dash you can buy the ability to
fly you know dash is actually something
that they that they you actually have to
buy so as you know it's pretty well
thought out in terms of you know how
getting someone used to using the store
in order to get the stuff they need to
get through the levels it does have a
lot of the standard issues in addition
to letterboxing
it actually misses the back key
navigation side it's pulled the hdmi
because I'm clumsy beer bottle was in
the way well that's also true so we can
go back to the game over for a little
bit it's just kind of show you all the
things that I wish the team was doing
the back he obviously does nothing here
which is sad and so I'm stuck using
things like this pause menu know if
you're really really cool if this
actually you know you know did dismiss
the pause menu at least the other things
we you know to note is um you know we
can when we hit the lock screen come
back it then actually does pause which
is cool yeah that's so that's a good way
to take care of the music / log screen
issue it was a good way to make sure
that your user isn't surprised by being
tossed directly back into a game that
they'd forgotten they were playing but
the really nice thing about the backing
this is the thing I was going to talk
about is that as I as i'm looking here
at this at this at this pause menu i'm
given pause menu i'd give it a bunch of
icons and there's this this this this
icon called shop in this icon that has
little dots and lines in the middle of
it and actually you know for me and I've
got this thing at the stop at the tart
start now the start restarts the level
it doesn't go back that one goes to the
menu which looks kind of like that but
not exactly the third one goes to the
shop now actually the back key is more
intuitive to me for going back then
actually having a bunch of lines with
some dots on it so you know I think I
think from uh from a perspective that
even if you don't play a whole lot of
angry birds games do you I did but even
with even it but angry birds i always
use the back here never I never hit that
you know yeah that looks like that so
yeah I think that you know from a
usability perspective it just you know
it just hits me like I might actually
not know what the difference between
these three keep those two top keys was
I might not even realize it was
restarted unless i play Angry Birds but
of course I have so that's just one
thing to note in terms of backe it's
it's just really important and
admittedly angry birds didn't always
support the back east hello and speaking
of backe it's generally considered a
no-no to actually have a key that that
has a back like this you know it on
logging greenbrier but yeah yeah because
you we generally think that android
users are going to use the back button
and in general you know obviously not
every android users you know feel
way but a lot of android users feel that
putting a back button up in the upper
left hand corner is proof that you've
sort of lazily ported over from another
operating system and honestly seeing the
letter boxing on this I I tend to agree
i think it was a a quick port from
something else so this went to our if
this went to our QA department and you
know what they're going to say is the
really letterbox they're going to say
really low res you know they're they're
going to they're going to say doesn't
have standard android navigation but the
gameplay idea is pretty cute and I think
I think I think that so I i I'd like to
see these although were a little more
animation yeah and like you're
transforming from this rolling doughnut
to this super doughnut and there's no
actual interstitial there that just
happens right absolutely but super
doughnut is really kind cute absolutely
i'm actually going to go turn on show
touches because i realized i turn it off
on this device so we can there you go so
hey I was looking at that you're angry
you are you all aren't seen where I'm
I'm actually touching so let me turn
that back on show screen touches not
flash up screen now see I want to show
touches are okay yeah yeah that's much
better alright so now when we need it
when we do the next game will see that
let's go on to ferry well no idea i
think actually from hot donut it makes
most sense to get a hot head very good
point so on so hot head actually
nominated the title big win soccer but
they didn't actually think we think
because it had it in him you know
include a link or anything or even any
comment as to what game they were
actually knowledge is that hey we're
awesome check out our video yeah and
which is cool and the video is awesome
yeah but they are kind of awesome we
were excited when hot head start making
android games we remember them from
deathspank on the xbox 360 I they
brought out see stars which you know
wasn't my cup of tea but I've got
friends that have been playing on that
everyone likes tea yeah that's is what
it comes down to actually no one likes
tea all right right so anyway I big win
soccer yeah looked like a really cool
game but I'm a lot more of a hockey fan
myself big win hockey actually came out
about the same time or a little before
that's what I wanted well so i think you
should demo this one because you are
totally the fan of this game yeah so
babe in hockey I mean I mean I mean Ian
basically said you know if we had to
pick a game that we were playing this
week this would be the one he would pick
that's my favorite game that's that I've
played this week yeah I mean I'm still
you know trying to 3 star level 7 on
radiant defense which I'm starting to
believe is impossible but thanks anyway
I've send them it's in minions way yes
no it's as far as games that have come
up this is just a really interesting
game and it's you know in some ways it's
transparent cash grab because it's it's
the sort of game where you really do
need to spend some money but I do
appreciate the fact that unlike some
transparent cash grab games it actually
is an actual android game okay well in a
major it's a really nice artwork
probably the best way to put it is it's
a it's a ccg right it's a collectible
card game yes and it feels just like any
collectible right and all collectible
card games are about buying cards so no
way to get around that however the real
question is once you've bought cards how
does it feel is it fun is it cool am I
glad that i bought the cards and the
answer my friends is yes and that reason
is right I just play hockey and no
matter how bad I am at hockey there are
people who do not have five dollars and
I do not anymore because you expected on
Carla's that is very true yeah I didn't
have to get google to expense that
anything but oh yeah I'm gonna get in
trouble anyways the point is that you go
and get these card packs so i can i can
get a set of cards and in this case I
think all i can afford is a bronze set
of cards so i'm not going to go buy
extras but um so I open a card pack I
love how they give you five choices
right yeah it makes any difference at
all I what it's like actually wedding in
other words you don't choose
you could have picked that one yes yes
need all right so you can o do I really
low i don't know i don't know maybe i
should have picked the second one okay
Sosh openings opening the card pack I
love the animations I'm a look at this
stuff is it's very very good rip a hole
particle system for opening the cardiac
that awesome zactly this is and in the
deck you get uniforms you get players
and you get these big impact cards the
idea is I that you're going to set up
your team with players that you get out
of card packs and you're going to add
big impact cards to your game and you
also get I don't think I got any players
even in this pack but I did get a skill
boost so I'll cool I feel like a toc
Iman that were or or exactly yeah or
happy the gathering yes so let's see how
how our team the puck droids does here
all right now notice I was able to press
the back button give now yeah they did a
bit of a job there we've actually worked
them a little bit there was some
unpredictable navigation at first I
they've really cleaned that up it looks
really good um so let me go to my team
so now i can set up my team and if i
want to i can i can change their uniform
so i get uniforms those are we totally
lame cards but hey some people like to
change the look of their team right well
that's true yeah I mean I'm not gonna
I'm I could say no to change and look at
my team especially because there are
some uniforms you can only get in the
better packs of cards do they have hats
or they all stock wearing these I know
they have no hats that's just so uh yeah
yeah exactly I they will I want I want
this stupid I'm you know spending time
in the Sun Hat yeah they will never look
like sissy spacek from cold water so it
looks like yeah none of those cards
actually doing any good but so I'm going
to go ahead and play a game now this is
where it kind of gets interesting and
this is where you know you're going to
realize that this is aimed at a
completely different set of people than
your average sports game because this is
not really a sports game
is it sin in a way it's a team
management game but in a way it's a game
for fans yeah you know you like this for
you like to watch the sport so look at
what happens here I'm going to go to
play and there's several different
things like it I can compete for trophy
with my friends there's a daily trophy
competition or how did you just when
your friends like this yes yes
strategize you know there is strategy to
picking the right deck you know so
exactly so yeah so now what I'm going to
do is I can i can say i'm going to say
use a big win tape to tape card you know
improves my teams passing okay they
could definitely use that i can pick up
to three of these takeaways i love that
one mmm um injury free well not unlike
that one you know what I'm only going to
use two okay yeah I'm not gonna yeah is
that when you remove when you use a card
though you can continue to use it for
Moto know those those things district
your games yeah you don't want to use
more than you have to yeah so so now
let's play so you can see our game the
puck droids you know thank God we have a
high resolution display that could be
misinterpreted easily absolutely um
their guy come buddy else's team I saw
that and I was just like I'm not making
that mistake not it not in the Friday
review now maybe it was the Friday
late-night review yeah that'd be one
thing you need to do that it is late
night somewhere so oh I think it's
actually late night where most of our
viewers are hello Czechoslovakia hope
you stayed around after rate of the show
what is awfully late you know that's
true okay so so we're going after the
miami heat in lower case um now the
truth is these games are all pre
predigested i mean the the outcome is
actually already known on the servers
but but what we get to do is watch the
game which is actually a hell of a lot
of fun even if you're not a huge hockey
fan but i do like the kind of you know
retro aesthetic to of the game yeah but
like you know it doesn't it doesn't look
like you know Gretzky hockey from like
you know even I think
you'd have to go back to like
1980-something for it to look like this
but it's cool so you can see that my big
wind card or my big was it big impact
cards are flashing over here and that's
because they're being used so anytime
you see those flash it means that that
particular skill is being used hmm so oh
cool i'm on a power play check that out
i wish you could hear the sound to ya
but oh man won't let us it's alright so
the really cool did ya see you know what
he played like Zen sounds on his show
but apparently no for games no
apparently at family that's because
there's n right parently do that's
because people who make snow an alarm
clocks are in a position it gives a
copyright on Zen I think that's just the
way it work with the clove will fix that
next time that seems like a dreadful you
know shot in the face to sound effects
artists everywhere yeah apparently we
don't care about you anyway the thing is
uh you get to watch this whole game it's
a lot of fun everytime videon says it's
actually not effing the opinion of
Google incorporated let's just make that
that's very true yeah okay it's very
true so join Google incorporated may not
have any fun playing this game I did
that's what I meant is that you can you
can watch a lame I you can you can play
through the whole tape or if you want
you can skip to the end and honestly
this this is just so fun so fun to watch
i usually don't watch a whole game the
one thing that i would love to have
though is the ability for know you have
a fast for we do it you high speed it up
oh well you just go to the paws minute
well so you can yep you can only skip I
I want a wide like warp speed yeah I
want to spit out the way to play to only
like a goal to goal and stuff like that
it's a good place so I you know that
that was my wheeling was yeah I want to
have the big hit big impact cards if i
press them it should actually bring up
the description again one of those
things yeah
I agree I mean they're true you know my
memory is not what it used to be but
still it really depends on how many of
these we've had no yeah that's right i
would just get another one I'd remember
all this stuff so let's go ahead and and
see the only man is in today's memory
improves so we'll go ahead and skip to
the end and look at checkout the a
lectroids one kopeck droid yeah um you
get all your stats apparently we had 13
shots on goal for to point out your your
your your big impact cards kicked by
that was yeah that's true they did you
didn't yeah so hey yeah and you can go
back and rewatch it or whatever I did
the main thing is now I'm going to
continue through this and you know I get
some fans blah blah so it's got all the
all the normal name elements but the
main thing is that I now have more coins
and I can use those coins to buy
additional card packs or of course i can
i can go buy coins using real money well
that's not that bad why is there
anything where you want to say about
this games mean is is that i think that
you know i think that there's a few
places where it was a little confusing
um the how the game navigated in fact I
remember when you know great on I talked
about this and we couldn't really decide
if you if you play a game and anything
about any cards Wow oh yeah yeah I'm
barebacking it oh yeah we're headed
popping sharpening skates taping sticks
coaches giving pep talks initializing a
big win not without any picking cat
impact cards probably yeah you never
know well look apparently the sconce
it's really good you know that's what
the problem with things that are named
based upon upon the the general group of
people out there when you play against
random players you just never know we're
going to get and in this case the
Australian relative of the Wolverine yes
exactly
alright so it's not so watch the game um
now when I when I'm inside the game the
back he does actually pretty much what
you'd expect which is it brings up this
pause menu and by the way the
presentation on this is really
professional now the truth is all of a
soft heart is space in my heart for
hockey games because the first game that
I worked on for the xbox one was a
hockey game called NHL rivals 2004 mhm
and I'd never watched hockey or even
been involved with anything honky like
before that I yeah but I did the
commentary system for it which entailed
trying to figure out why its machi rules
and things like that sad memories of a
little kid of going to hockey games and
shivering in the stands with my dad you
know you know that that was appropriate
you know fairly semi regular occurrence
back then that was before hockey got
expenses you say hey a lot as a child
was actually in Los Angeles which is
just about the only place there was
hockey on the west coast back then and
button by the way you know the Kings are
actually one went away right now from
winning the Stanley Cup so it is it I
have no idea it Wow yeah which is
something I've never done in the 42
years or so that they've been together
why yeah all right so anyway yeah I
point is that I've worked on these games
I I think this is a very professional I
mean there's you know obviously if you
were on a massive you know pc or xbox
360 playstation 3 um you know you
probably be doing a lot more than this
but just all of the animation and the
way the graphics have been done is
really high quality the only objection
that i have is they were not authorized
for a 720p screen they're just a little
bit grainy I think you can probably see
that on your screen you've just got a
little bit of stretching there but this
also shows that even even with just a
you know if you there is a little bit of
stretching like the difference between
this game you know I showing a full
screen display you know with a little
bit of stretching because the assets
aren't exactly the right size and for
example showing the game compressed and
with giant black borders around all
sides is you know i mean this is this is
you know
definitely definitely superior to that
and and so you know you know you know
even though it kind of shows that you
know the most important thing is to make
sure you're designing for aspect ratios
and it's great to have a really high
resolution art assets but you can get
away with a little bit of it in here
this is you can and I think and I think
that you know you can try to figure out
where your target is you know I mean
they're going to be you know eventually
devices that are going to be super super
high resolution we've got xhdpi you know
and so and and and so when those devices
ship you know there are there is going
to be need for higher art but you know
there's always going to be some sort of
point of you know it just doesn't make
much difference anymore right and now
you know this game I think has a
presentation it looks good enough as it
is it's beautiful i'm really impressed
by it yeah hit the back button again it
just misses that perfect now what
happens when I skip to the end okay I
hit the back button here nothing happens
the question we had and we yet so we
talked to the guys a hothead and they're
like well it has no meaning there it's
the end of the game and so what we were
trying to figure out is what is the best
way to handle that a doublet lee well of
course it has it has meaning and you
know in the back in the back button
always should take you out of the
current task and you know so right now
we've got two options rewatch and
continue continue would take you this
popularity screen and and the back
button here doesn't doesn't work which i
think is totally wrong i think you know
we just went to another screen yeah and
i think i should be able to go back to
the previous screen well also also from
a point from a point of the game is is I
expect wanting at the back key that I'm
gonna be allowed to exit now the truth
is I don't need to see that popularity
stuff i would actually assume that if i
hit the back key at this point i would
go straight here yeah you know and I
could just go back to the main I would
go back to their menu that's that's
about that that's what would make sense
i think that you know that being said
because you might lose that internet
context you might say you might pop up
something inside would you like to
return to the main menu because there
are options are only available there and
we do try to do you know operate by the
principle of least disruption when it
comes to the back key so i would say
that would be reasonable to me but i
think it should definitely go back here
though this is the ultimate destination
at the end up again and to be honest
I meant I don't want to see that I've
just lost I don't really need to see all
that junk you know I'm what I want to
get back here as quickly as possible to
start losing again this is a little
frustrating yeah I obviously haven't
spent enough money on this particular
team yeah exactly i will try its need to
do some yeah work ya know any today to
do puck up yeah yeah exactly so I you
can you can get the free books and I
think this is a you know probably a tap
joy offer wall or yeah i think so that's
really looks like it yeah um this is you
know a lot of people do this please join
major offer walls look better on tablets
yeah we're coming from it looks better
than it used to I mean given yeah it
used to be either used to go to a tax
write off a wall and it looked like
something that was written on the side
of a bathroom or some janky webpage it
looked like this couldn't possibly be
real this is actually looking better
believe it or not but it's still like
dude something cool on tablets oh my god
it's just it would be so nice yeah
actually what I'd really love to see i'd
love to see what what what android or
google play does which is put this whole
thing into a pop-up so so it's a correct
width and the game still behind it you
could certainly do that i mean the other
thing you could do is i mean i would
love to see that honestly would help
their their their advertisers that you
know if they just had some more rich
space and i like to see some content
like I want to see Netflix and I want to
see you know here's why I want it i want
to go to netflix you know it's not just
by getting five-pointer netflix it's
like this is a chance to give their
advertisers to more space something I
know that's absolutely true I know I say
take advantage of tablet stuff you know
or in a worst-case put make two columns
of you you know is the other option so
there there's plenty of ways of dealing
with this alright so let's continue on
all right so anyway to wrap up a big win
hockey and honestly big win soccer is
pretty much the same game just with more
people and games more boring um the I'm
making a comment about the sport of
course not about I was going to say I
actually the Gators a talk with a panic
it is very nearly identical anyway it's
a fun game and the point that we really
want to make though is that hard head
has taken a lot of care to make it
a beautiful game and also to make it an
android game they've really thought
about how things are navigating is I'm
Android app and they pretty much do
everything right yes it's pretty close
you know my general feeling is that you
know in this even in this kind of game I
would rather see them rather than pop up
a menu in the middle of the game I would
rather see them just go back to the main
screen have the option to continue a
game in progress you know kill the game
in progress if you know which basically
means finish it you know it's not so I
mean I think I think you could go one
step further but I think it's certainly
there's nothing in it would get with
that are that are you know featuring
group would it would have got to you
know I think and I and I think that it's
tough because this particular genre
always makes me think of console yeah
it's an eight and that pause menu
popping up is exactly what you want yeah
it's certainly a I would say is even
built my only comment amount was because
it's not a real time game like you know
usually what we say is pop up the pause
menu if it's going to be really
disruptive right to stop again because
this isn't real time you know I think it
even better is it's a hairy dude you've
got a game in progress if you liked it
would you like to watch it or would you
like to just see what happened yeah that
guy didn't thing and I think while
you're at it some VCR controls for the
game I know in terms of that you know
not only being able to pause and resume
it also fast fast reward look I'd love
to see like just between shots I love to
be able to show me the next goal show me
the next goal show me the next highlight
you know I'd love to see a highlight
reel the game instead of watching the
whole game that would be cool awesome
beaches data to highlight reel and now
absolute not whether you're good post
your highlight you real to youtube and
when you can monetize in all sorts of
wit and by the way this is what a lot of
people don't realize is if you post
gameplay footage to YouTube you do have
the ability as the game developer to
monetize ads that are attached to that
so if you're if you're a YouTube partner
and and you know you it works just like
any other content posted to youtube so
it's something it's something to think
about as you're developing mobile titles
i think you know my general feeling is
monetize as many ways as you possibly
can and that are within policy and so
you know by that I think I think there's
a lot of unexplored territory and how
you can deal with user-generated content
and you know perhaps this game isn't
ticular user-generated yes but I think
people might be excited about the way
their cards play out so you never know
and you know the best thing about it is
is that people might be driven to watch
that footage and then might be driven to
actually play your game in addition to
potentially getting getting Mon station
so i think is a great story it's a
win-win yeah all right lightning round
all right we are three cubes all right
so this is this is a totally cute game
you've got one minute and the main
second the main problem with it is that
it just doesn't navigate and wow that's
wild I've never seen that happen it's
displaying two different things one of
the main screen in one of these on the
secondary screen oh it must be because
it's using the media player I know well
that is really cool I've never seen that
happen before well this is where its
we're actually not seeing yeah you're
seeing yeah that's that's why I was like
so let's continue any all right so yeah
there's what we're seeing so we're not
seeing ourselves yeah well that's what
we're saying so um so what's funny about
this game first of all is it when you
start the game the first time it
actually and you actually go to do a
game it actually gives you this even if
you don't have a game in progress which
was kind of weird in the back he doesn't
do anything here you notice that's the
first thing I notice really you you
didn't look at the picture of the ferry
no sir oh there's a ferry there with kit
cube um and uh yeah I don't know why but
it disturbs me oh maybe it's the dead
look in her eyes it's is it all right
let's do a game no definitely a guy
actually have no prior to resume your
artist so um so yeah so the base debate
it's a match-three style game that's in
sort of a 3d environment which is cool
now this is the first thing that second
thing I noticed is I went to click on
level nine like I want to start hearing
that does nothing oh yes it's a
selection game we have to hit started
and I was like why do I have to do that
yeah go first puzzle that is the first
toss anticipation this is like 3d
mahjongg it is it you think that it's
like pretty it's a pretty game yeah I
know it is it looks exactly like 3d
model well you actually do is just grab
threes and just pick them out of here
and you've got items that are getting
stacked so it's which is sort of like a
kind of Tetris thing where you're saying
things your goal is to clear things off
the board and as you clear different
sets of items off the board you will
feel stopped showing up in the side here
which is what you need to clear off
things
can't get rid of in threes and and you
know the first I don't know ten levels
the gate or nine levels of the game or
so are are are actually pretty
straightforwardly easy and now our study
super stuff we have to use one of these
that is available on the side over there
and I've got it now I've got to use two
of these you get you actually lose
points i think for using the ones on the
side instead of using the ones that are
on the screen as you can see if you have
a point you can't make a move and this
all completely fills up you lose the
round so i'm going to make it this time
but just barely as long as I'm fast
enough and what oh I had to have that
once don't even notice that one okay so
bottom line really nice looking game has
some interesting gameplay could probably
use a lot of work on the interstitials
and the UI yeah yeah and and so the
other thing to to note on this on this
yeah there's a lot of stuff
interstitials there's a lot of stuff
with the you know navigation navigation
is the biggest problem with this game
right navigation okay lightning
remaining on all right any farm tiny
farm so I on this is a game that I that
was featured at some point I think and
and it's actually a beautifully
beautifully done game a couple of things
one is that this game is is big and as a
secondary download I'd love to see them
using apk expansion files another thing
is it it actually has a bunch of
navigation problems i think if we are
for our QA look at this today they would
say no you know like you hit the back
key here and it just says exit and
that's you know that's it but i really
be cool with that we're not now yeah and
actually but actually if you look here
within within the within the gameplay
itself it also has vistage with vested
Oh menu kids it do nothing but if you
look within the gameplay itself there's
all sorts of places in which it feels
like you should be able to go go back
and dismiss things and none of them work
they all they all just say don't x they
also know I didn't want to exit the game
I just wanted your stupid dialogue to go
away now what's funny you know you
actually can at some you can't actually
go click here and click exit game which
takes you back to the main menu which
also you can't get to rig bays in the
back use there's tons and tons of places
where this game navigates wrong so so
fix it because it's really cute game and
then that if you like clicking cows this
is a game for you yeah lightning round
all right yeah absolutely okie dokie is
a classic and there's actually a set
there's actually at least two versions
of okie actually on on google play and
it is why am I not surprised you're like
an Okie connoisseur I am NOT an Okie
goddess here this is this is a game
that's apparently very popular in in
Turkey according to the game developers
which I believe are from Poland and so
how you play the game is it's actually
it's actually a multiplayer game I would
I would be curious to see a multiplayer
version of this game clearly that's how
it's intended to be played so now I've
got some choices up I'm trying to build
sets here and my goal is I can either
pull from this might late my player to
my left well I can pick a random card of
which there are 47 once all the cards
are picked because this is sort of a
lightning round of the game the game
will end and this game actually does
just about everything right like you hit
the back key here and it has other than
some you know missing grammar well you
know it actually does something quite
reasonable i hit the back again it goes
away that's good it looks like a
dialogue that makes sense now i would
much rather for this kind of game just
like a thing i'd much rather have it
actually just go back to the main menu
and let me continue like there should
just be a big old button there this is
continuing there should never be a
pop-up that says that I mean really like
especially especially since I'm not
really playing against people now I was
really playing against people there was
some network or some local connection
that might be broken that's actually one
of those rare cases in which it is
really very reasonable to have a pop-up
like that you know if I'm actually like
tearing down a network connection or
something like that you know I can and
and other people might might believe
that I'm going to lose progress now once
again there's two pieces of progress
that we really care about you using
there's progress in the game and there's
parts in terms of time so if I'm going
to have to replay a section of the game
or if I'm going to have to wait for
something to load then it's fine to pop
up a notification and make somebody
confirm that they really want to go back
otherwise it should just happen again
you know that again we wanted to make
sure is that you know what a game gets
gets featured on google play you know
they're looking to see
it comply with the android-navigation
paradigm mateo popping up a dialogue
when the back he hits is sort of
borderline we don't really do it in our
applications we go to extreme measures
to try to not do that you know so if
you're in the middle of editing
something in gmail it does not pop up a
dialog and say you're the middle of
editing something would you like to quit
the way it does if you're on yon on the
website at times you know actually it
actually says boom saves it is draft and
bam you're gone and that's and that's
really kind of the key thing is you know
you want to make sure that as much as
possible it just feels like magic when
you go in and out of things you should
build a multi task kind of effortlessly
and that really extends the games as
well so again there's nothing that would
keep this game from being featured I
actually confirmation dialog isn't wrong
it's just it's not as professional as
just making it magic absolutely not even
and might min my feeling is you know
this I have all the games we reviewed
this is if this is one of this is
probably one of the simplest games but
it's actually very ready it looks fair
that I don't know a good job it looks
good on on the Galaxy Nexus you know I
if you like this this particular
gameplay and you eventually what you do
is by the way when the cars run out in
this version of the game it's the number
of upsets you have whether they are
multiples or they are they are different
two sets of what's the word anyway
exactly I I clearly remember I think
that is actually a last name i'll ask 80
we have had a great time this week we
hope you have to please I don't forget
to go to our moderator page and vote for
the apps and games that you would like
to see on the Friday review or submit
your own remember to submit them under
the Friday app review or Friday games
review we know there's a lot of links on
that moderator and it can be a little
confusing but the Friday app review and
friday game review links are the ones
that you want so go ahead and nominate
your games nominate your apps and tune
in next week for another Friday review
thanks a lot thank you cheers
you